The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BORIS KATZ: When
a scientist though
approaches a complex phenomena
or when an engineer looks
at a difficult problem, they
usually break it up into pieces
and try to understand
this phenomena
and solve them separately.
Understanding intelligence is
one such very, very complex,
in fact, extraordinary complex
problem, and over the years,
this divide and conquer
approach produced
a number of very
successful fields
like computer vision,
natural language processing,
cognitive science, neuroscience,
machine vision, and so on.
But we need to remember
the most cognitive tasks
that humans perform actually
go across modalities,
which is they span these
established fields.
And the goal of our thrust is
to bring together techniques
from all these fields,
create new models,
and for solving
intelligence task,
we also would like to understand
how these tasks operate
in the brain.
So I will start with one task,
which is scene recognition.
What does scene
recognition involve?
Well, machines, in order
to recognize a scene,
a machine needs to do
some type of verification.
Is that a street lamp?
It uses the detection of
other people in the scene.
It needs to do identification.
Is this particular
building, Potala Palace,
somewhere in Tibet?
It needs to do object
categorization.
Look at this image
and tell me where
are mountains, trees, buildings,
street lamps, vendors, people,
and so forth.
We should also be able
to recognize activity.
What is this person doing?
Or what are these
two guys doing here?
Well, currently, our
machines are pretty
bad at all of these tasks.
I understand that there has
been quite a lot of progress
recently made in
machine learning.
And I've also seen some claims
that machines perform better
than humans in
some visual tasks.
However, I think we
should take these claims
with a grain of salt.
First, there is nothing
amazing about machines
doing certain things
better than humans.
People did it over millennia.
Humans needed tools
to build pyramids.
They build tools to carry
heavy things, to lift them,
to go faster, and so on.
Well, you'll tell me,
no, no, no, we need,
we are talking about
intelligent tasks.
Well, for $5 you
can buy a calculator
that multiplies numbers
much better than you do.
For $100, you can build a gadget
that has a huge lookup table
and plays chess much
better than any of you.
So when you hear that a
computer can distinguish
between 20 breeds of dogs,
or something like that,
better than you
do, I don't think
you should assume that the
vision problem is solved.
Well, understand, I'm not
saying that because we have
a dramatically better solution.
Not at all.
My point is that the problems
of real visual understanding
and real language understanding
are extraordinary hard,
and we need to be patient
and try to understand why
and eventually find
better solutions.
So back to visual
understanding problem.
So as I said, machines are
better at these things.
But humans are
absolutely awesome.
You have absolutely no trouble
to do verification detection,
identification, categorization.
You could do much
more than that.
You could recognize spatial
and temporal relationships
between objects.
You can do event recognition.
You can explain things.
You can look at that
image that I showed you
and tell me what past
events caused the scene
to look like it is.
You can look at that scene and
say what future events might
occur in that scene.
You can fill gaps.
You can hallucinate things.
You could tell me
what objects which
were included in that
scene which I've barely
seen, actually, there
might be present there
and what events not visible in
the scene could have occurred.
So why are machines
are falling short?
Well, in part, our
visual system is
tuned to process structures
typically found in the world,
but our machines have no idea.
They don't know
enough about the world
and they don't know what
structures and events make
sense and typically
happen in the world.
So I will show you
a blurry video.
And I wonder if,
well, some of you
who didn't see it, whether
you could figure out what's
going on.
Who have not seen this video?
Could you tell me what you saw?
AUDIENCE: A person was talking
on the phone then switched
to working on his computer
BORIS KATZ: Right.
Well, this is amazing.
Even with almost no
pixels there and you still
recognize what's going
on, well, because you know
what typically
happens in the world.
Well, of course it
was sort of a joke
and people sometimes
make mistakes, too.
So here's the unblurred video.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
Well, but, all jokes aside.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
BORIS KATZ: Jokes
aside, though, it
would have been extraordinary
if our machines could
make mistakes like this.
Not even close.
Well, so we may want to
ask ourselves questions.
How is this knowledge that
you seem to have is obtained?
And how can we pass this
knowledge to our computers?
How can we determine whether
this computer knowledge
is correct?
Our partial answer
is using language.
And I bolded the
word partial here,
because clearly there are
many other ways humans obtain
knowledge about the
world, but today I
will be talking about
language and show you
what is needed to give
knowledge to the machine.
So we have a proposal.
We would like to create
a knowledge base that
contains descriptions
of objects,
their properties, the
relations between them
as they're typically
found in the world,
and we want to
make this knowledge
base available to a
scene-recognition system.
And to test the
performance of the system,
we will ask natural
language questions.
One of us here
has decided to see
what questions
people actually ask,
and he set up an
Amazon Turk experiment,
where he showed people
hundreds of images
and asked them to write
down, generate questions
about these images.
And I will show you a couple.
Here's a scene.
In here, the questions
that people ask,
you know, how many
men in the picture?
What's in the cart?
What does the number
on the sign say?
Is there any luggage?
What is the color of
shirt of some lady?
Another example.
Who is winning, yellow or red?
Well, the answer is, of course,
red, but how did you do that?
Well, you need to know that
this is a sporting event, which
all of you do.
That it involves, in
this particular sporting
event, winners and
losers, that you do.
It needs to know that this
sort of short-hand yellow
and the red means people
wearing these colors,
rather than color themselves.
You need to know to pay no
attention to people wearing red
or maybe blue in the audience.
And you also need to know that
a participant on the floor
is likely a loser, not a winner.
That's a lot of knowledge.
So, back to our proposal.
We want to try to
give at least some
of that knowledge
using language,
and for that, of
course, we need tools.
And over the years, we've built
a system called START, which,
in fact, contains
some tools that
could be helpful for this task.
And I will be happy to
share the API with you
so that you could use
the system and maybe
try to see what to do with the
knowledge that you give it.
So there are only three
tools on this slide.
So one is going from
language to structure.
So we know that to provide
machines with knowledge,
we give the machine a bunch of
sentences, texts, paragraphs,
and that will be
converted into some kind
of semantic representation.
And I will show some
details of that.
We want to go the
other direction.
We want a machine to
explain what it does
or describe its
knowledge using language.
So we have a generator
that does that, that
goes from semantic
representation to language.
And we want to test the
machine, because it's
very important to
know whether what
you thought the machine, if
actually it understood you
correctly.
We want to ask
questions, give queries.
Those will be converted in
semantic representations that
will be matched against
what the machine knows.
And the computer will either
give you a language response
or perform some actions,
which will indicate that it
understood what you asked.
So we will go
through these tools
and I will describe you
the START system in detail,
but I just want you to remember
that this is a discipline
and engineering
enterprise and these
are the tools that I want
to give you and other people
so that you could start thinking
deeper about human abilities
and modalities, like vision
and language and others.
Some of the building
blocks of the START system.
We need to parse
language, we need
to come up with
semantic representation,
generate match,
reply, and so forth.
So let's very quickly
go through that.
Most of you, somewhere
in middle school,
learned about parse trees.
Linguists love them.
They're beautiful.
This is an example of a
sentence from Tom Sawyer.
Tom greeted his
aunt who was sitting
by an open window in a
pleasant rearward apartment.
And linguists like to
argue about exactly
the representations, but
pretty much most of them
will agree that something
like that represents
the structure, the syntactic
structure of the sentence.
Well, they're
beautiful and nice,
but they're really
horrible if you
want to store them, if
you want to match them,
if you want to
retrieve from them.
And so we use the information
found in parse trees,
but we developed a
different representation
which we call Ternary
expression representation, which
is a more semantic
representation of language.
It is syntax-driven, but it
highlights semantic relations
which humans find
important, and it also,
because we give this
knowledge to computers,
we made it very efficient
for indexing, for matching,
and for retrieval.
It's also reversible, and
I'll explain in a second what
I mean by that.
We implemented it as a
nested subject, relation,
object set of tuples.
So here is a different sentence.
Say you have an image.
You may recognize one of the
characters there in the back.
It's Andrei Barbu.
And say you want to describe,
in language, what you see here.
And you say something
like, the person
who picked up the yellow
lemon placed it in the bowl
on the table.
Using this structure, subject,
relation, object structure,
you could, and first
parsing the sentence,
you could create this
Ternary expression.
And you could see,
person picked up lemon.
That same person placed that
lemon in the bowl on the table,
and that lemon
happens to be yellow.
To make it a little
bit more easy
for you to see what's going
on and convenient for humans
and machines, we created a sort
of topologically equivalent
linearization of that
graph, that knowledge
graph, and as a set of triples.
They're a little
bit misleading here
just due to its simplicity,
but all words here, of course,
need to have an index,
because if you have,
say, a tall person
and a short person
or, then, you will have to
distinguish between them.
So you need indices,
but for simplicity, I
didn't show them here.
And then the verbs
also have indices
so that when you use the
same word place here,
that is the relation,
the triple, that
happened to be in the
bowl, that the person
placed a lemon in the bowl.
So this is all
representation and when
we distinguished at least three
types of Ternary expressions.
So the first type you see
here, syntactic structure
of a sentence.
We also have syntactic features.
The fact that the sitting
was, it was past tense.
She was sitting, it said here.
But it's a progressive
tense, was sitting, and also
what kind of
article things have.
The window had an article
and an indefinite article.
And also the lexical features
that don't change from sentence
to sentence, the fact that Tom
is a proper noun and so forth.
Well, I told you that our
representation is reversible.
Well, we need to be able to
teach machines to talk to us.
And there are many
reasons to do that.
Some of them are
shown on this slide.
We want your robot
or your computer
to explain what it
does somewhat remotely.
You want your
machine or your robot
to answer questions
which are complex
and the robot may want to ask
you about it for clarification.
You want to keep track of
conversation history and state.
Engage in
mixed-initiative dialogue.
Offer related information.
So all these things need
to happen in the dialogue
and, therefore,
your computer must
be able to speak to you in a
language that you understand.
In fact, I find that the biggest
problem with learning systems
that we have today is
that some of the work
can work quite
robustly, and sometimes
give you good results,
but you have no idea why.
You press a button, you
say, aha, here's the number,
and put it in the paper,
but more recently, people
started looking at why
it does what it does.
But, again, it's
done by numbers.
It would be really
wonderful if our learning
system could tell us why they
came up with their conclusions.
So we need language
and so we created,
sort of built a
START generator that
goes from those same expressions
and create natural language.
This is why we call this
representation reversable.
So given a set of
Ternary expressions,
the machine will
create a sentence,
the person who picked out
the yellow lemon placed it
in the bowl on the table.
But, of course, this
is a little bit silly,
just parroting the
same sentence back.
You want the
machine, for example,
as I said, to ask you
a question or indicate
a negative statement or rephrase
it from different pieces
that it knows about.
So, in fact, our generator
is very flexible.
So here is an example where
by, say, observing the world,
robot adds more information
to this representation,
and they're indicated
here in blue.
And now from the
original sentence about,
which was the person who
picked out the yellow lemon,
placed it in the
bowl, the machine,
by just adding a couple
of new relations,
the generator will be able to
ask a question, or the human.
Will the person who placed
the yellow lemon in the bowl
on the table pick it up soon?
And so forth.
All right, so we talked
about parse trees,
about semantic representation,
about generation.
So what do we do with that?
Let's-- Supposing that you gave
some knowledge to your machine,
hear that Tom Sawyer assertion,
and somebody asked you,
was anyone sitting
by an open window?
Well, what needs to
happen is this question
needs to be converted into
Ternary representation
as I indicated, and this
knowledge base, we assume,
had the knowledge from the
original assertion plus million
other assertions, of course.
So we would need to match the
representation of the query
with the knowledge base,
and the machine will say,
aha, here is the match.
Well, this is very
simple here, if you
think window needs
to open to window,
open to match window open,
open, and sit and sit,
and then the word anyone, which
sort of matching the word,
needs to match aunt.
But, in reality,
of course, people
ask questions which do
not that closely follow
what the machine knows,
and so for our matcher,
it needs to be much
more sophisticated.
This is just the graphical
effect, sort of knowledge,
graph representation
of that match.
So START distinguishes
things like term matching,
which as I showed, could
be a lexical match.
Of course, it knows synonym.
It knows hyponymy
when it goes one way.
It's like a car is a vehicle.
And as you can imagine, the
match also needs to go one way.
If I say I bought a car, it also
means that I bought a vehicle.
But if I say I bought
a vehicle, it's
not true that I bought
a car because I may have
bought a truck, but this aside.
So it's pretty easy to do
matching on the level of terms
of words, but a much
more complex problem
is to match on the
level of the structure.
And I will show you some
examples of this problem.
But by now, you must
have figured out
I love to stare at
English sentences.
I hope you do a little bit.
If not, please try.
So here, let's consider
a couple of verbs.
So here is the verb surprise.
Let's consider
these two sentences.
The patient surprised the
doctor with his fast recovery.
The patient's fast recovery
surprised the doctor.
Now for you who are used
to understanding language
so quickly, it's even
hard to hear what's
different about the sentences.
But if you actually
do the parsing,
you will see that the parse
trees are dramatically
different, and therefore,
our Ternary representations
will be very different.
So we need to find a way
to tell the machine, yeah,
that's the same thing.
And the linguists call
these things syntactic
alternations as well.
In a different verb like load,
here's a different alternation.
The crane loaded the ship
with containers or the crane
loaded containers onto the ship.
Again, means the same
thing pretty much,
but the surface
representation is different.
The next one is in
terms of a question.
Did Iran provide
Syria with weapons
or did Iran provide
weapons to Syria?
Let's see if it's true for
every verb in the universe.
So let's try to look at the,
say, surprise alternation
and use it with a load verb
or the other way around.
So I hope you're
bearing with me.
So linguists put stars in
front of bad sentences.
And so here I tried to
use the word surprise
without alternation, which
load allows you to do.
Here, you do the same onto, and
it says the patient surprised
fast recovery onto the doctor.
It makes absolutely no sense.
Here I tried to do surprise
alternation for the word load.
And it says the crane's
containers loaded the ship.
Again, complete gibberish.
And the same below.
Did Iran's weapons
provide Syria?
So it looks like a
really horrible story.
Every English verb,
it looks like,
has a different way of saying,
expressing these alternations,
but fortunately,
this is not the case.
Let's go back to
the verb surprise.
Well, let's look at verbs
similar to the word surprise.
So you could use
the same alternation
with the word confused.
You can say the patient
confused the doctor
with slow recovery,
which will convert
into the patient's slow
recovery confused the doctor.
You can say the same
thing with anger,
disappoint, embarrass, fight,
and impress, please, threaten.
And what is really amazing
about it and very interesting
that this syntactic
alternation works
the same way for verbs
of the same meaning,
of the same semantic class.
And this particular class is
called the emotional reaction
verbs.
And it's a large semantic
class of about 300 verbs,
and they all behave
identically from the point
of view of that alternations.
And it's true for all other
alternations that I showed you.
So that's, of
course, is good news
because it makes an interesting
connection between syntax
and semantics,
but it also allows
to build lexicons that are
more compact and easier
to deal with.
And one can imagine creating
this verb membership
automatically by
looking at large corpus.
And this is how,
presumably, children
learn these verb classes
and these alternations.
All right, so now that
you know how to match
and it's not just
trivial match only,
like I showed here, but a
more sophisticated match
on the level of
structure as well,
let's see what we can do
after the match happens.
So here's the same sentence
and the same question.
Was anybody sitting
by an open window?
We retrieved the
structure and then
we could tell our generator,
go and generate the sentence,
and it will do that.
Tom's aunt was sitting
by an open window
in a pleasant
rearward apartment.
Well, it's not as interesting.
It's sort of parroting the
same thing I tell it, ABC,
and it told me
back, ABC, if I ask
who BC or something like that.
If you want to build a
question-answering system,
we want it to be able to,
in response to a question,
understand it, go somewhere,
find the right answer,
and give it back to you.
And we build that and we
do it by a general, where,
if looking at it, our system can
execute a procedure in response
to a match to obtain the
answer from the data source.
So an example is here and I
can show you some screenshots
or, in fact, if you like it, we
can play with the system live
and you'll see what it does.
So it executes a procedure to
obtain an answer from the data
source.
If you say who directed Gone
With the Wind, from match,
it will happen between what
you know, what you ask,
and what the system knows,
some script will get executed
and the machine will go to some
data source, find the answer,
and give it back to you.
So how this is done?
Well, in order to explain
that, I need two more ideas.
One is a natural
language annotation idea.
So annotations,
sentences, and phrases
that describe the content
of retrievable information
segments, this is a graphic
sort of, in a cute way,
show this sentence level,
or phrase level labels
on some data, and they describe
the retrievable information
segments.
Annotations are then matched
against submitted queries
and the successful
match results in,
either retrieval of that
information or some procedure,
to retrieve that information.
And the special case
of this procedure
is done using our
object-property-value data
model.
This technique can
connect language
to arbitrary procedures,
but as I said,
let's consider a lot of
semi-structured information
sources available
on the web that
can be modeled using this
object-property-value model.
Well, what are these,
what kind of repositories
have this property?
If you think about
it, almost anything
that humans create on the
web, which is semi-structured,
is like that.
If you have a site that
has a bunch of countries
with properties like
populations, areas
capitals, birthrates, and
so forth, the country is
an object, the word
population is a property,
and value is the actual
value of that property.
You can have people
with their birth-dates,
you can have cities with maps
and elevations and so forth.
So in a sense, this
object-property-value model
makes it possible to view and
use large segments of the web
as a database.
And schematically, here's
how START uses this model.
A user asks the language
part of the system
a question, the system needs
to understand the question,
understands where the
question might be found,
and what is the
object and property
implicit in the question.
After START does
that, it says it
has a friend called Omnibase,
and it says, go get it.
Go to this site.
Go for that symbol called France
and go get the population.
And it will go to
some world fact book
and get the population.
So this is how the
system works and here's
an example of such a question.
Here, the question
is, it's a screenshot,
does Russia border on Moldova?
The system says, ah ha,
you want to find out
what countries border
Moldova, and find out
whether Russia is among them.
And then it actually checks that
and it tells you, no, Russia
does not border Moldova,
because it doesn't
find Russia in this response.
And just for comparison, if
you ask the same question
of a search engine,
it will give you
24 million results, today
maybe 240 million results,
and none of them really
answer the question.
Well, I just want to tell you
that the ability to understand
something really helps.
In this case, the ability
to understand language
gives you a lot of power.
You can do a lot by trying
through the keywords
and you can retrieve
a lot of documents,
and this is how all of, pretty
much, modern systems work.
But if you want to do something
a little bit more complex,
it would be nice
to understand some.
So here's an example
of a complex question.
Who is the president of
the fourth largest country
married to?
Well, if you can analyze
this question into pieces,
then you can very quickly
figure out that, right away,
just throwing the pieces
on your knowledge base,
you cannot resolve it.
But we've built a very nice
syntatical-based algorithm
that allows us to resolve the
complex questions into subsets
of simpler questions and
understand in which order
to ask them.
So the machine
will say, oh, first
I need to find out what's
the fourth largest country,
then who its president
is, and then with that,
who he is married to.
And, very quickly, this is
how, schematically, it's done.
This is sort of
an under the hood
Ternary expression
representation of the question.
The machine says, oh,
too hard, let's first
find out what the fourth
largest country is.
It's China.
Then let's find out,
it's still hard,
so let's find out who
the president of China
is, found the name, and then
the next is just a lookup table.
Who is he married to?
And it gives you an answer.
Some other examples.
In what city was the fifth
president of the US born?
And finds like a James Monroe
and gives you the city.
What books did the author
of War and Peace write?
Finds Leo Tolstoy and finds his
books from different sources.
So the technology
that I described,
object-property-value data
model, our Ternary expression
representation, complex question
answering, the annotation,
natural language
annotation, representation.
They, over the years,
inspired a bunch of companies
and a bunch of technologies,
starting with Ask Jeeves, who,
I guess, existed before
you guys were even born,
to Wolfram Alpha,
who pretty much took
[INAUDIBLE] wholesale,
to more recently,
Google QA started doing
really wonderful things using
this idea that, everybody
had the idea that you should
go from surface to a question.
If you have a question,
you throw your question
onto the web and
you get some answer,
but it doesn't work
with high precision.
So the idea that you need to
curate knowledge and build
some huge depository
of knowledge
was picked up by these
companies to, certainly now,
all these companies do quite
decent question answering.
And the same is true
for Watson and Siri,
and I was involved in
some of these things,
so I will show you.
Let's see.
Right, so let's start with this.
About 10 years ago,
we, on top of START,
we built a system that was
connected to a cell phone.
I don't know how many of
you remember the world
without smartphones,
but that was
when smartphones wasn't there.
There was no such
thing as iPhone.
So there's a vanilla
phone that, all it did, it
made phone calls.
Of course, it also had a
camera and unlimited text.
But it really
didn't do much more
and we decided it's time
to connect it to language.
So we convinced the company
to fund us to do that,
and we build some language
called StartMobile.
And this is an intelligent
phone assistant,
which could, at the time,
retrieve general purpose
information, provide access
to computational services,
perform action on another
phone, trigger apparatus,
like a camera on a phone,
receive instructions.
And we have a,
talking about YouTube,
we have a video that shows
the system in action.
That video is quite old.
It's from beginning of
2006, and at the time,
we did not connect
to speech, but you
could see what it
does by, the user
was typing in questions
for the system
in that particular video.
So there's no narration so
if you read the captions,
you'll figure out
what is going on.
So here's my former
student, who actually
went to Google to transition
our technology eventually.
And he's not sure whether he
needs to take his coat or not.
[JAZZ MUSIC]
Again, this is very
dated, of course,
because now the temperature
is almost uniform,
but, again, that
was 10 years ago.
Is there any sound?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BORIS KATZ: All
right, those of you
that know Cambridge
know that station.
Where am I?
The GPS just came about and
we were lucky to connect it
and so now the guy gets
the map and knows where
to find where he needs to go.
So this is our data center
for those who haven't seen it.
This is where CSAIL is.
Again, it's dated, because
right now this lawn
is a huge building, but it
wasn't there at the time.
Oh it says here, trying
to reach my mother.
I don't know why it shows
you this stuff, but.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BORIS KATZ: He's
worried about his mother
and so he decides to tell
her, remind my mother
to take her medicine
at 3:00 p.m.
And we'll see what
happens with that later.
Take a higher resolution picture
using flash in 10 seconds.
I don't think any phones can do
it even today for some reason.
I don't know why it's so hard.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: For a selfie.
BORIS KATZ: Right, for a selfie.
Very good, yeah.
All right, so his
friend is busy and he
wants to entertain
himself, I guess,
but he doesn't quite
know how to do it.
How do I use the
radio on my phone?
Well.
All right, now he knows.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, mother's health.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
Right, so, exactly.
So a delayed accident
happened on her phone
so we inserted the
thing on her phone
and then she got this
warning, and that's my stuff.
They all turned out to
be very good actors.
All right, so this
is the last thing.
Traveling, she is going back.
She now has a car.
And this is the last
thing that I'll show you.
[JAZZ MUSIC]
How do I get from here
to Frederica's house?
Well, if you think about it,
this is a very hard question.
You need to know
that here is here
and go to GPS and
find the location.
You need to know
Frederica's house
from your list of contacts
that need to go there,
and you need to then send it
to, in that case, we send it to,
I believe it was
MapQuest, I don't even
know if it exists now, to
actually give the directions.
Well, anyway, so.
Well, it was a little bit
of a sad story actually.
So we built the system.
The company that I
mentioned was Nokia.
We showed them the demo.
They were very excited about it.
They said, well, can we
put START on the phone?
Because in that
application, the signals
were sent to MIT from
the phone and the answers
were sending back to the phone.
I said, well, it
doesn't seem right.
START is large and
there was no internet
that could take care of that.
They said, no, no, no,
how big is your system?
Can you talk through the company
to put it to a LISP compiler,
to put it on our
chip, and so forth.
We need another phone.
Unfortunately, the word cloud
hadn't been invented yet.
Maybe I would have been more
eloquent in explaining to them
why they don't need to have
the system on the phone.
And so they didn't want
to use that the way it is.
We wrote a paper,
showed it to them,
say, do something about
this, it will be too late.
And right at that time, Apple
released its first iPhone.
So I go to like
senior vice president
and say, look, these
guys are ahead of you.
You should decide
about it because they
will do what I gave you.
He asking, how many iPhones
did Apple sell last month?
I said I read somewhere
like a couple of thousand.
And he starts
laughing hysterically.
He said, we, my company, ships
one million phones every day.
Why do we care about
Apple, he said.
Well, so, we gave this talk.
That was September 2007 by then.
In December, somebody started
a company called Siri,
and then two years later,
Siri was bought by Apple
and the rest is history.
And Nokia was sold pretty
much on a yard sale
and doesn't exist anymore.
So be visionary.
Don't think that you know what
you are doing all the time.
Yeah, people often ask me to
say a few words about Jeopardy!.
The question that the IBM
team was hoping to answer
was actually a very
important question.
Can we create a computer system
to compete against the best
human in a task,
which is normally
thought to require high
level of human intelligence?
I was involved with them
from the very beginning
for various reasons
which I will not go into.
They put together a wonderful
team, some really good people,
very devoted people.
They spent four or five years
of their life, pretty much,
totally devoted to that.
And they built a system,
and these are the kind of,
I guess--
I don't know if any of you
know what Jeopardy! is but
pretty much, people
ask the question,
which for various reasons, is
formulated not as a question
but as an assertion,
with the most
to reflect these
that are pronouns
and you need to give an answer,
which they call the question,
for some reason.
There's a gimmick.
You have to say what is
envelope instead of envelope,
but let's not pay
attention to that.
It doesn't matter.
And this is very hard.
To push one of
these paper products
is to stretch the
established limits,
and you need to figure out
that to push the envelopes
means stretch
established limits.
This is a idiom for those
of you who are not native.
And the answer is envelope.
A simple question is the
chapels of these colleges were
designed by this architect?
And you need to figure out that
Christopher Wren is the answer.
Of course, many questions
involve a question
decomposition.
So here's an example
of a real question.
Of the four countries in the
world that the US does not
have diplomatic relations with,
the one that's farthest north?
So it's pretty much
asking several questions.
One is the sort of
inner sub-question.
The four countries in
the world that the US
doesn't have relations with,
and the outer sub-question
is, now that you know the answer
of these four countries, which
is the farthest north?
You do a little
bit of arithmetics
and you find the
answer is North Korea.
And of course, this is very
similar to what started years
before, is pretty much
you decompose the question
and you solve them
separately, as I showed you
a few minutes ago.
So Watson actually
took a bunch of ideas
from START, the Ternary
expression representation,
the natural language
annotations idea,
the object-property-value
data model, and the question
decomposition model,
and applied them
when they could really
analyze syntactically
the question where the question
was not too convoluted,
and when there was a
semi-structured resource,
or several resources,
to find an answer.
But many questions, of
course, were not like that,
and stretching the
envelope is one example.
And so Watson used some
statistical machine
learning approaches and
they did quite a good job
of looking at a lot of
data to resolve and answer
these questions.
Their pipeline is,
really, miles long,
because each of
these bullets has
three, which are
a bunch of bullets
with a bunch of bullets that
the task that they were doing,
but on a very high level, they
needed to content acquisition.
Pretty much, all right,
there was a problem.
The company, Jeopardy!, told
them the web cannot be part
of that because everything
that Google knows everything.
So what is it that
you guys are doing?
So they had, so what would you
do if somebody tells you you
cannot use the word?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BORIS KATZ: What's that?
BORIS KATZ: Well, you
pretty much bring the web
and put it in a box.
And this is what IBM did.
They took every repository,
interesting repository,
every database, every
encyclopedia, every newspaper
collection, I forgot where
the blogs existed at the time,
and just had a lot
of clusters and a lot
of memory and
everything was there.
So now they could tell
the company no web.
We are smart without the web.
So that was the first thing.
Then, they actually, there were
some wonderful natural language
processing people do, so
they did question answering,
they searched the documents.
So what they really did, they
took the clue, they call it,
the question, throw it on
not the web but on their web,
find tens of
thousands of documents
that even closely
match these keywords,
and then the real
work just started.
They had this kind of filtering,
that kind of filtering,
this kind of answer
generation, that kind of.
They would score it, they
will pay new evidence,
they will do it again,
they will do ranking,
and they will decide how
confident they are about that
and then they will
decide whether it's worth
how much they spent,
incredible amount of time
figuring out how much money.
I don't actually know
much about Jeopardy!,
but apparently you have to tell
them how good you answered.
Well, you need to come up with
a number of how expensive you
are, how much you
will make if you win,
and how much you
lose if you lose.
And so they did it all and
they built a wonderful system.
In the beginning, when
I started going there,
that was very, very slow.
It ran on a single processor
and really took two hours
to do this pipeline.
But that, if you think about it,
it's a very plausible problem.
You could send it
all to, in that case,
I think by the end it was
like several thousand cores,
and they easily reduced
the time to three seconds,
which was passable and
doable for the competition.
And so they won,
as you all know.
It's a great system
that nails the state
of the art in natural
language, in QA, in information
retrieval, machine learning.
It's a great piece
of engineering.
It reignited, no doubts about
it, public interest in AI.
It brought new talented
people in our field.
So this is all great news.
But let's look at some
of the sort of blunders
that occurred, well, both before
the competition and after.
I had a whole bunch,
a collection of those.
I'll just show you a couple.
This actually happened
before the competition
so they figured the problem.
So the question was,
again, it's called
a clue, in a category of
letters, in the late 40s,
a mother wrote to this artist
that his picture, number nine,
looked like her son's
finger paintings.
Well, for those who
are quick at that,
I'm sure you know that
it's Jackson Pollock,
but Watson sent Rembrandt
for some stupid reasons.
It failed to recognize that
late 40s referred to 1940s,
or rather they thought it's
made in previous centuries,
and apparently, it has something
to do with number nine.
That was in a bunch of
documents related to Rembrandt
and so it said Rembrandt.
Another more famous blunder,
because that happened
at the competition, the
category was US city,
and the question was
its, which is a series,
largest airport is named
for a World War II hero,
and its second largest
for a World War II battle.
And again, those of
you quick at that
will know that in Chicago
there is this O'Hare Airport
and he happened to be
famous here from the world.
And the second
airport called Midway,
which is a famous battle
in the Second World War.
And Watson presses the
button and says Toronto.
And there's a sort of
gasp in the audience,
and also like tens of millions
or hundreds of millions
television sets
around the world.
And again, there are
some stupid reasons.
Watson did machine
learning, as I said,
and it statistically figured
out the category part
of the clue, which in this
case, since this is a US city,
it might not be that
important, so we should
pay less attention to it.
It also knew that Toronto
team playing in baseball--
is that true?
Yes.
In the US baseball
league, and that, in fact,
one of Toronto's airport
is named for a hero.
Although, it's a
World War I hero.
So it put it all together
and said Toronto.
In any case, it won anyway
because it did an amazing job
on answering many
more questions,
but the question to us
is whether this is what
we should all be striving for.
I'm certainly all in favor
of building awesome systems,
and they did, and I explained
to you why I think it's good,
but IBM has not created a
machine that thinks like us.
And what's in success
didn't bring us
even an inch closer
to understanding
human intelligence.
And the positive
news, of course,
is that there was those
blunders, should remind us
that the problem is
waiting to be solved
and you guys are in good
positions to try to do that.
And that should be our
next big challenge.